if grand theft auto online has been a
boring drive for you recently fear not
rockstar has just released a new mode
that's sure to tick things into high
gear it's called every bullet counts and
it definitely sounds like it lives up to
the name this new mode pits four players
against each other in close quarters
everyone gets a pistol but it only holds
two shots this means you'll have to be
very strategic in both moving around and
pulling the trigger once that chamber is
empty you'll have to resort to melee
tactics if you want to off your
opponents what's more you won't be able
to can't or wait behind a corner stay
still for five seconds and your location
is pinned on the map every bullet counts
and so does every move this free-for-all
mode is available right now but only on
playstation 4 xbox one and pc and
keeping with rockstars plan to focus on
current generation platforms it will not
be coming to the ps3 or 360 check back
soon for gamespot's look at the new mode
i'm tony wilson you can follow me on
twitter at chain gun pope and i'm going
to keep looking for that jetpack